MEETING WITH A TOP NORTH KOREAN
OFFICIAL IN NEW YORK CITY.
IT'S TIME FOR THE VERY IMPORTANT
FAST-PACED BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
IN EARLY MARCH LAST YEAR, JEFF
SESSIONS WAS NEW ON THE JOB.
HE WAS JUST APPOINTED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND JUST
CONFIRMED BY HIS FORMER PEERS IN
THE U.S. SENATE.
HE SAID HE UPHOLD THE LAW AS THE
TOP COP.
HE DECIDED TO RECUSE HIMSELF
FROM THE SINGLE BIGGEST, MOST
IMPORTANT CASE FACING THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
THE ONGOING SO-CALLED RUSSIA
COLLUSION INVESTIGATION.
SO WE HAVE THE COUNTRY'S TOP
LAWYER IMMEDIATELY RECUSING
HIMSELF FROM THE SINGLE MOST
PRESSING CASE TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
OR THOSE THAT CONFIRMED HIM TO
THE U.S. SENATE.
YOU PROBABLY REMEMBER THIS.
>> I ASKED FOR THE CANDIDATE AND
HONEST OPINION ABOUT WHAT I
SHOULD DO ABOUT CERTAIN
INVESTIGATIONS.
MY STAFF RECOMMENDED RECUSAL.
THEY SAID THAT SINCE I HAD
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE CAMPAIGN, I
SHOULD NOT BE INVOLVED IN ANY
CAMPAIGN INVESTIGATION.
I HAVE STUDIED THE RULES AND
CONSIDERED THEIR COMMENTS AND
EVALUATION.
I BELIEVE THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE RIGHT AND JUST.
THEREFORE, I HAVE RECUSED MYSELF
IN THE MATTERS THAT DEAL WITH
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: YEAH, CAREER PEOPLE.
WHAT FORMER SENATOR AND ATTORNEY
JEFF SESSIONS DID AT THIS POINT
IS SO HARMFUL.
THE RAMIFICATIONS SO MASSIVE,
HIS DECISION THAT DAY, THE DAY
AFTER HE'S CONFIRMED, IS PLAYING
OUT TODAY.
IT'S HURTING THE COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO FOX NEWS LEGAL
ANALYST, GREGG JARRETT WILL JOIN
US SOON, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
USED A COMPLETELY ILL LEGITIMATE
JUSTIFICATION FOR HIS RECUSE
SAL.
SESSIONS RECITED THAT HE WAS
REQUIRED TO RECUSE HIMSELF UNDER
U.S. CODE, FEDERAL REGULATIONS
BECAUSE OF AN ONGOING CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
HOWEVER, AT THE TIME OF
SESSIONS' RECUSAL, THERE WAS NO
RUSSIA COLLUSION CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
IT WAS A COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
INQUIRY.
THE INVESTIGATION ONLY STARTED
AFTER SESSIONS RECUSAL OF ROBERT
MUELLER.
NOW ROBERT MUELLER IS EVEN
REPORTEDLY INVESTIGATING NOW,
DESPERATE, PANICKING, HE KNOWS
THIS IS BLOWING UP, A MEETING
THAT TOOK PLACE BETWEEN TRUMP
AND SESSIONS THAT TOOK PLACE
SHORTLY AFTER THE PRESIDENT WAS
BLINDSIDED BY HIS OWN ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S DECISION TO RECUSE
HIMSELF ON DAY ONE.
DOES ANYONE EXPECT A SITTING
U.S. PRESIDENT NOT TO QUESTION
HIS BRAND NEW ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
DECISION TO SIT ON THE
SIDELINES, RECUSE HIMSELF THE
DAY AFTER HE IS LITERALLY
CONFIRMED IN A CASE WHEN HE'S
TAKEN THE JOB THE NEXT DAY?
BY THE WAY, THE PRESIDENT CAN
ORDER AN ATTORNEY GENERAL AS
GREGG JARRETT TOLD US LAST NIGHT
TO INDICTMENT, TO MAKE AN
INDICTMENT, NOT MAKE AN
INDICTMENT, TO INVESTIGATE OR
NOT INVESTIGATE SOMETHING.
SO THERE'S FRANKLY NOTHING
UNUSUAL OR ILLEGAL AND THIS
MEETING.
WE'LL HAVE FULL ANALYSIS AND
MORE ON THE MUELLER ISSUE IN
JUST A MOMENT.
TONIGHT, SO MANY OTHER IMPORTANT
LINGERING QUESTIONS FOR JEFF
SESSIONS.
WHY DIDN'T HE TELL ANYBODY THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT HE WAS GOING TO
RECUSE HIMSELF BEFORE HE WAS
CONFIRMED?
OR BEFORE HE WAS APPOINTED?
HOW IN GOOD FAITH CAN AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT WITHOUT
PARTICIPATING IN THE SINGLE MOST
PRESSING LEGAL CASE FACING THIS
COUNTRY, FACING THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND NOW WE CAN
ALL SEE THE DAMAGE OF MUELLER'S
WITCH HUNT INVESTIGATION AND
WHAT IT IS.
A FLAWED WITCH HUNT, WHY HE
SHOULD, AS WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
MONTHS AND MONTHS AGO, UNRECUSE
HIMSELF IMMEDIATELY.
THIS TIME HE WOULD BE FOLLOWING
THE CORRECT LAW WITHOUT A DOUBT
WHEN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SITUATIONS.
WELL, I HAVE PERSONALLY ALWAYS
LIKED AND RESPECTED.
WHAT HE'S DONE HERE HAS NOW LEFT
THIS ADMINISTRATION AND COUNTRY
MORE EXPOSED TO THE DEEP STATE
THAT HAS BEEN WORKING AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT YOU ELECTED SINCE
THE VERY BEGINNING.
JUST LAST WEEK WE LEARNED THAT
ONE INFORMANT, LIKELY MORE,
WORKING IN COORDINATION WITH THE
OBAMA JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
ACTIVELY INFILTRATING THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, SPYING ON A MULTITUDE
OF PEOPLE ASSOCIATED WITHIN CAN
TRUMP'S ELECTION EFFORTS.
HERE'S WHAT TWO OF THE MEN THAT
WERE SPIED ON HAD TO SAY ON THIS
PROGRAM RIGHT HERE LAST NIGHT.
TAKE A LOOK.
ABOUT WAS THAT THE USE ME AS A
WAY TO GET AN INTRODUCTION TO
GEORGE.
HE WANTED TO GO TO GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS.
HE USED CARTER PAGE TO GET TO ME
AND ME TO GET TO GEORGE.
THAT WAS THE WHOLE CHAIN HOFF
EVENTS THERE.
>> I BELIEVE I GOT TWO OR MORE
APPROACHES BY INDIVIDUALS TRYING
TO OFFERED INFORMATION TO THE
CAMPAIGN THAT WOULD HAVE JAMMED
US UP IN SOME WAY, SHAPE OR
FORM.
IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT SAM AND
CARTER WERE BOTH APPROACHED BY A
SPY.
>> Sean: LYING TO FISA JUDGES
REPEATEDLY, NOT TELLING THE
JUDGES, NO CORROBORATING, NOT
VERIFYING, NOT TELLING FISA
COURT JUDGES, SPYING ON TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATES.
ALL OF THIS HAPPENED.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
NOW WE HAVE SPIES THAT WE'RE
DISCOVERING THAT WERE IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AS THE MEDIA SAYS IT'S NOT
SPYING, IT'S AN INFORMANT.
YOU JUST HEARD BY THE THREE MEN
THAT WERE APPROACHED BY THE
INFORMANT TO TELL THEM AND SEEK
OUT INFORMATION BECAUSE OF THIS
WITCH HUNT AS WE BEGAN AS WE NOW
KNOW IN THE SPRING OF 2016.
I LISTENED TO CHAIRMAN GOWDY WHO
I FRANKLY AGREE ON A LOT OF
ISSUES.
LET'S MAKE THIS VERY SIMPLE.
HERE'S THE BASIC -- THE
DEFINITION OF THE TERM SPY FOR
ALL OF YOU PEOPLE IN CONGRESS,
EVEN THOSE OF YOU THAT CLAIM TO
BE LAWYERS, A SECRET OR
UNDERCOVER AGENT, THAT'S A SPY.
SO MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WAS SPIED ON.
A SECRET AGENT WORKING WITH
OBAMA'S JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
MONITORING CONVERSATION AND
ACTIVITIES OF MANY TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATES.
YOU JUST HEARD DIRECTLY FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE SPIED ON
AND ACTIVELY TARGETED BY THE
SPY.
CHAIRMAN GOWDY PRAISING THE
FBI'S OVERALL HANDLING OF THE
RUSSIA PROBE.
NO, LOOK AT McCABE, COMEY,
STRZOK, LORETTA LYNCH, ALL THE
OTHERS THAT ABUSED THEIR POWER.
SO WE HAVE TO GET THIS RIGHT.
THE FBI LITERALLY UNDER FIRED
FBI DIRECTOR WHICH THE PRESIDENT
HAD EVERY RIGHT TO DO, ROD
ROSENSTEIN DIRECTED, USED
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DIRTY DOSSIER FULL OF
RUSSIAN LIES PUT TOGETHER BY A
FOREIGN
FOREIG
FOREIGN AGENT AND ILLEGALLY
CONVINCED FISA JUSTS TO
AUTHORIZE A WIRETAP AGAINST A
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE IN A
LEAD UP TO A CAMPAIGN WHILE THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION IS
UNMASKING THE NAMES OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS CAUGHT UP IN OTHER
SURVEILLANCE AT WHAT IS A 350%
INCREASE FROM ANY PRIOR YEAR AND
WHILE THE FBI WAS USING SPIES TO
MONITOR AT LEAST FOUR PEOPLE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
CHAIRMAN GOWDY, KEEPING UP?
LET'S NOT FORGET AFTER JAMES
COMEY WAS FIRED, COMEY ILLEGALLY
LEAKED DOCUMENTS.
HE WANTED TO PROMPT THE APPOINT
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR CUTER.
BECAUSE THE MOST MERRY BAND OF
ANTI-TRUMP DONORS, THOSE PEOPLE
THAT ARE DOING EVERYTHING IN
THEIR POWER TO TAKE THIS
PRESIDENT DOWN.
HOW WOULD YOU TRUST UNTIL THAT
HIRES ANDREW THE PITBULL
WISEMAN?
HE OVERTURNED SECURITY 9-0, PUT
FOUR INNOCENT MARYLAND
EXECUTIVES IN JAIL FOR A YEAR
AND OVERTURNED BY THE FIFTH
CIRCUIT.
YOU WANT HIM INVESTIGATING YOU?
GIVE ME A CALL.
THERE'S SO MANY BRAVE PUBLIC
SERVANTS THAT ARE DOING
IMPORTANT WORK IN THE FBI.
IN THE CIA.
IN OUR INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
SOME VERY HIGH-RANKING.
BUT WE HAVE NOW DISCOVERED ABUSE
OF POWER, BAD APPLES THAT HAVE A
POLITICAL AGENDA THAT ARE HELL
BENT ON DESTROYING THIS
PRESIDENT, DELEGITIMIZING HIM
AND RUINING THE VOTE OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BY THE WAY, IN THEIR EYES, THIS
WAS THE MAN THAT WAS NEVER
SUPPOSED TO BE PRESIDENT AND
THEY WERE COUNTING ON IT.
THERE WERE FEARS THAT MUELLER'S
PROBE WILL DETERMINE THE
MID-TERM ELECTION.
RUDY GULIANI WHO IS WITH US
TONIGHT WILL JOIN US LIVE IN A
LITTLE BIT, WEIGHED IN ON THIS
EARLIER TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WILL
MEDDLE --
>> IF HE DOESN'T FILE HIS REPORT
BY SEPTEMBER 1, MID SEPTEMBER --
>> WILL HE FIRE HIM?
>> I DON'T THINK HE'S GOING TO
FIRE HIM.
>> MAYBE A MISTAKE.
MAYBE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT IMPEACHMENT IS
THEY'RE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO SAY THEY'RE GOING TO
IMPEACH HIM.
>> Sean: SO TONIGHT IT'S NOT
JUST PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT'S NOT REPUBLICANS WORRIED
ABOUT THIS POLITICAL IMPACT OF
MUELLER'S PARTISAN FISHING
EXPEDITION.
HE COULDN'T FIND ONE TRUMP
DONOR, NOT ONE.
IN FACT, TOP SENATE DEMOCRAT HAS
POLITICAL FEARS KICKING IN.
MARK WARNER SAYS HE FEARS
AMERICANS WILL START TO GROW
TIRED OF THE INVESTIGATION IF
IT'S NOT WRAPPED UP THIS YEAR.
OH, YEAH.
THEY'RE TIRED OF IT ALREADY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE NOTION FOR THOSE THAT MAY
BE PARTISANS IN THE CROWD THAT
SAY, IF THE DEMOCRATS TAKE
CONTROL, THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
REALLY RAMP THESE UP.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PUBLIC WILL
BE TIRED OF IT IF THIS DOES NOT
WIND DOWN IN THIS CALENDAR YEAR.
>> Sean: WHAT DID THE JUDGE SAY?
WHY DID HE GO BACK TO PAUL
MANAFORT'S CASE?
PUT THE SCREWS TO HIM SO THEY
CAN GET INFORMATION THEY CAN USE
TO PROSECUTE OR IMPEACH A
SITTING PRESIDENT, A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
THAT JUDGE WAS DEAD-ON ACCURATE.
ACCORDING TO A NEW POLL FROM CBS
NEWS, A MAJORITY OF YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU ARE RIGHTLY
NOW ALREADY SKEPTICAL OF
MUELLER'S EFFORTS BELIEVING THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S INVESTIGATION
IS WHAT IT IS, POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED.
WHILE THIS OFF-THE-RAILS RUSSIA
SO-CALLED INVESTIGATION ROLLS ON
WAY PASSED, WAY BEYOND ANY
MANDATE THEY EVER HAD, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
HE ACTUALLY HAS REAL WORK TO GET
DONE.
INCLUDING NEGOTIATIONS WITH
NORTH KOREA.
ALREADY THE PRESIDENT HAS
SECURED THE RELEASE OF SEVERAL
HOSTAGES HELD CAPTIVE IN NORTH
KOREA.
KIM JONG-UN IS NO LONGER FIRING
MISSILES OVER JAPAN AND
THREATENING GUAM OR THE UNITED
STATES.
THE NUCLEAR TESTS HAVE HALTED.
HE CROSSED THE DMZ.
HOURS AGO A TOP NORTH KOREAN
OFFICIAL LANDED IN NEW YORK CITY
FOR A MEETING WITH MIKE POMPEO.
THE TWO MEN JUST FINISHED A
WORKING DINNER.